[Music]
it stopped its 2018 there's a lot of
problems in the world
I'm woke and I'm not doing this weekend
scramble thing anymore
we're serious news just serious news
let's do it
take it away might go this week this
week we've got smart mirror gasps
backlash and pregnancy discounts I think
it thought you for one pregnancy nope
yes the front first story amazon has
recently been awarded a patent to use a
system of cameras projectors and mirrors
to layer like a digital image reflection
of your bodies it can give you tips on
your outfits and make sure it is like
the mirror actually can change its
background so you could be on a beach or
you could be like this [ __ ] next left
yeah the catfishing is gonna be so much
easier for me now what machine the
catfishing 18 now you can't say [ __ ]
like that just pretend like you know it
no I do know what happen she was but I
didn't see how she was gonna do it
because her famous it's usually like Oh
random I would be Gina on the Internet
yeah I'll catfished my life like I'll
just be like my life is so fabulous and
I'm like in different places but I'm
actually crying in my bedroom this seems
like we're stepping backwards to me
really well like what about like Tupac
performed at Coachella or whatever yeah
that's hologram help me obi-wan Kenobi
you're my only hope
yeah well I mean why can't they just do
that that could be the neck right it
kind of went for it cuz now they're
bringing similar technology into your
own tree I feel like I'm the [ __ ]
schmuck Catelli I'm not
Italian person what is this mud I'm
gonna do they send me like a box of
cameras and [ __ ] you set it up and then
you can [ __ ] see what you would look
like your name is home box they've
released this new product that's called
echo look and so it's this camera that
you could set up anywhere and it could
take a photo of you and I'm gonna show
you guys a video as to what else is not
the government's doing this time Amazon
for president is it echo their little
fangs ons grateful customers not for the
people that work there yes it goes like
their little iGoogle home slash theory
slash whatever Alexa that's the fun echo
maybes like okay no Alexis with Amazon
ass [ __ ] porn girl-on-girl this video
right here is you know she's a hologram
no so this is a promo video for the echo
look which is a camera now what we're
talking about now is that Amazon was
recently awarded a patent in order to
use this technology in a mirror I do
like though that I've been seeing more
Asians in commercials yeah thank you
feel brave you know why is because like
Asians by technology things so they put
us in there but they'll never put us in
about wiser put you and everything yeah
you're in everything now I want to see
red stripe I want to see Budweiser I
want to see hey sorry and all that
Jamaican wait do you have cable yeah you
do commercials on I don't want you know
I have pre-rolls on my YouTube oh but
every few now is awesome
really yeah car insurance all kind of so
we don't have to fight the fight anymore
we want it we want a quality there we go
yeah
car commercials not movies though not
move okay we got to keep I gotta keep
okay all right let's do it
okay here we go Alexa take a photo just
being Chinese introducing echos of a
first-of-its-kind echo with the hand
speed cameras echo look takes photos
using gesture voice its built-in
lighting and depth-sensing camera lets
you blur the backgrounds to make sure
your outfits pop giving you clean
full-length photos that are easy to
share with friends plus get a live view
or take videos to see yourself from
every angle we've also created an easy
way to get a second opinion introducing
style check it combines the best in
machine learning with advice from
fashion specialists just pick two
outfits and style check we'll give you a
recommendation based on current trends
and what flatters you Alexa can also
help you create a personal lookbook it
shows you what you are and when so you
can keep track of your favorites and
take your closet with you wherever you
go
yeah so that's pretty much your product
that this is to next level I don't even
know what to make of this [ __ ] I I just
immediately thought about like how great
are the portals gonna be now 360 VR yup
and then you you could do it like
there's gonna be so much couple point
cuz they're not afraid to like film yeah
so this product right now is by invite
only you can't you can't purchase this
unless you especially invited don't
tantalize me you know invite me were
more inviting us we're all social media
influencers schmucko Telly's I spent so
much money on Amazon please say you're
like me - I don't need this [ __ ] there's
a mirror patent I do we place on the
beach if you want I have imagination
there's like [ __ ] like a good on the
kid I want to buy a car tire rack mommy
you choose your car yeah get the burner
your rims on it like these rims a core I
want that color cars put it up higher
tire rack it's just like a car it's a
place to buy rims I like yeah they had
that they had that like in probably 2001
and it would just be it was a bad
picture but a pen it's a bad picture
yeah yeah it really is and then the rims
look and it isn't just a size just looks
stupid but I started realizing that I
would like to buy better clothes and
cars and stuff on GTA cuz you know you
have like you have like a Barbie doll
it's like a Barbie doll for guys you
could go to the you could go shopping
and I'm like oh [ __ ] suits are pretty
cool you know and then I was like you
know what after all this robbing and
stealing I do want a better house
I do want a better car I think I think
it's time to grow up GT a [ __ ] an
adult GTA really taught me how to be a
man all those beatin hookers and robbing
people made you an adult heard that a
very knowledgeable statement made via
what kind of genius statement made by a
hall do you think he was my Eric's
friend like eighteen year old where his
mom so he plays a lot of video games and
kind of violent video games at his mom's
like you're you're gonna pick up on
these bad tendencies when you play this
game so much and then he's like what
how's that gonna happen like you watch
cooking videos all the time and you
can't cook for [ __ ] cooking yeah and the
moms like good point damn if that if
muscles have that [ __ ] to me I'll be
like enjoy starving job mom for the fire
station yeah I'll be like no no no this
is dinner that I could get my disgusting
dinner you got to make your own dude and
watch it's like better than mine and
cook now this would be really good for
like fashion influencers and stuff be
cool but I want to know how quickly they
respond to you to tell you what you
should or should not wear imagine what
happened mirror is there something wrong
there's no suggestions though I feel
like I still feel like Holograms should
be there I feel like we should leap this
step I'm not with it because did you
guys watch the movie clueless yes from
like the nineteen 1800s
and then end it like it styles her so
she's like it's like her body and then
the clothes that like it starts
suggesting what she should put I think
that's what we need
no no just like in Miss Congeniality we
had that program to were like the dress
yeah make her over but I think that only
works if you already have style and have
those items this will help people that
don't have style and don't have those
items then it's not gonna help it
defeats the purpose right it's gonna
make them look really [ __ ] up less
[ __ ] up yeah I make them look less
[ __ ] up I don't think it's gonna work
what if they were able to do it like you
know those old Barbie dress-up games
like we need you to take a photo posing
like this and then they have already
clothes that they have yeah that's the
clueless oh I would love that that's
what this is wouldn't a shirt goes like
this though when the shirt goes like
this
you'll be naked yeah we stand up naked
bridge I'll just pose make it and then
send it and they're like no I want you
to stop my boxers what if like your
style is so incredibly Miche like
they're like oh you should wear the
skirt today and then it's just like a
goth Punk girl to half shaved head like
I don't think that's issues this will
make everybody look the same maybe yeah
so it's like how held so they're gonna
start discriminating styles oh my god
that's so [ __ ] up how can they do that
know what they're really gonna do is be
able to push their own Amazon clothes
you're welcome that's what they're doing
in here - no I don't buy much of
anything but I do know that like if you
go like echo or whatever like echo by me
i phone charger they send you Amazon
Amazon's iPhone charger no style is so
next level that nowhere has what I need
oh my god I totally forgot I got you a
gift I forgot to bring it really yeah I
got off me Amazon - yeah you know that
that the fanny pedal is like a hairy
belly yeah I got that telling me I could
get that I was like joke it I can't do
this without it Jo like I had to buy it
next time yeah yeah
next story or again people in Oregon are
pretty pissed that now starting in 2018
millions of pump their own gas you know
that's the craziest thing because when I
first witnessed that like we were doing
a road trip and then I was on the you
know I was in the family van and someone
was like pumping gas for us and I was
like oh you mean like my full service
yeah an organ it's only full so it was
it was I think other states - holy [ __ ]
so states that have a population of less
than four thousand forty thousand yeah
they people just walk up and then they
fill up your and my dad was like what
the hell yeah County County with less
than forty thousand people in Taiwan
it's only full-service
yeah there's no self-service unless you
ride a motorcycle it's like that in
Mexico to attend Japan to policing okay
Noah why or why not
but cuz we would it used to be same as
with gas well that's funny because a lot
of people like people in Oregon taking
our jobs are against it they're like I
don't want to go to work smelling like
gas oh yeah I don't want to pump my own
gas and like prevent like possibly blow
things up my [ __ ] Zoolander I do get a
little paranoid I read they have like
warnings about cigarettes obviously but
I think they ever want warnings about
cellphones like static electric are you
scared I'm like don't touch my phone
right now
that's crazy ass oh yeah yeah you gotta
have a foot on my tire and I'm texting
people extra [ __ ] bull there be my
song comments saying like what if I
can't Rob the moment again I'm like yes
important when I was reading these
comments you know like craziest concerns
I couldn't tell if it was serious you're
not where people really seriously
concerned about these things you did say
it's also counties with less than how
many people forty thousand almost they
don't have crime they have serial
killers that's true
how many people you think are woods and
serial killers
that's true they got that neighborhood
countable what I still don't get why or
why not some would make the decision or
a county or a city or state to do one of
the other like it seems irrelevant to me
yeah why is it mandatory that someone
pump your gas or even the officer though
why's the mandatory we do I don't know
like there's not full service here
really right there used to be fool and
self yeah like if you if you went to the
gas station back in a day there'll be a
sign that says full yeah and then they
run out and then they pump you are you
supposed to tipple no I don't know I
forgot I was I was always a kid when I
saw I'd imagine you would like a couple
years ago I pulled up to extol yes bill
and I forgot where I was I pulled up and
then I heard that Bell that thinking I
was like and then there was someone over
the intercom and said oh that pump is
full service do you want someone to come
out and help you and I'm like oh [ __ ]
did it come out like an addicted and say
what would you like ma'am you know what
would be tight though if instead of the
full service of pumping the gas I could
do it myself
but if there's an iPad and I can order
items from inside and someone delivers
of ten you grow two barn an energy drink
or water or whatever coffee that's cool
every time yeah like I would like it to
be like a pit stop
yeah cool up anything they pump your gas
people shine your tires [ __ ] they like
give you a quick hand job and on your
way full service keep it like the
[ __ ] racing pit yeah yeah full
service duty to relax with yeah like
your idea - that's awesome yeah yeah
it's a grill be like trucker guy hey pal
I saw your amazon pictures
yes soft hands and greasy fingers from
this sandwich where our last flesh is
flesh that is a new one
$20 is $20 was 2017 flesh
you're gonna think differently Oh his
where his hands are rough like human
flesh just flushes flush
yeah yeah dog flesh lamb flesh they got
very foolish mmm yeah maybe if it's a
hairless Chihuahua
we'll talk Oh Fink's uncomfortable now
all right so for our last story IKEA in
Sweden speed and speed they they have a
magazine ad that has a built-in
pregnancy test and it p on this add
positive you can take that add to the
store and get a free crib
get a discount on a crew smart burn
cream I'm gonna piss on your [ __ ] or
whatever it's like why would you want to
collect piss coupons
I think we're skipping over why is there
a magazine in 2018 yeah but why though
cuz there's older people yeah but first
my mom still around your mom still they
know how to use auto my mom prefers
print a hundred percent yeah cuz her
eyesight's bad - so phone this big she
can't read her tablet either she has a
tablet did she wear her glasses like
this no no no you know I like old people
they think I do the lip thing when I
read you know far away does this thing
know cuz like she's trying to catch a
much oh it's always the faces yeah yeah
that's what she did I love you mom yes
on the bottom here you see this like
white rectangle that is a pregnancy test
I think we have that crib actually but
in white now that exact one
yeah you should away we don't know we
don't we don't have it do you cut it out
or do you like like how do you do it you
just pee on the paper you hold the paper
in to speak you roll up the magazine you
stick it in mm-hmm
but asked that I keep telling you
there's different hope this is the page
okay yep and then you find up
are you funnel it you funneled it that's
not what he meant
if you did that I'd know it him funnel
it like um like you're like you're
changing your oil and then you put it in
like that how RP thing is are traveling
oh yeah I'm just standing here yeah it's
that I'm a genius
no you know they make it for girls I
should get peeing on the side of a road
or something yeah yeah you could pee
standing up so to take a copper look
yeah yeah you put it your girl urinal
yeah pretty much you can use it your and
all those against your hoo-ha and
they're like there's a good I don't have
a hoo-ha are you sure about that
mommy you have a kajigger Oh what let's
run future up that's a male hoo-ha
sounds kinda racist on [ __ ] yeah but a
lot of people they saw this and they got
upset because they were saying that it
was kind of sex it can be sexist so
funny that you guys gonna be on it if
they want right you imagine reading a
[ __ ] IKEA and you're like ooh we'll
stop rubbing all your pregnancy and
issues in our face all right they're
they're just saying like it can be
construed as sexist in what way because
like a woman can pee on it
yeah what about us I feel kind of left
out here I'm you know what this is not
fair I wanna pee on every magazine I see
now heard some of these companies have
such a system algorithm whatever that
they'll know you're pregnant before
you're you know you're pregnant
yeah what what does so like Walmart
based on what you buy for months can
know you're pregnant before you're
pregnant oh they're stocking up on
diapers or based on spending pattern
once you have just bought a extra lot of
chocolate and some extra vitamins like
some shit's happening like and you're
just buying more fruit for no reason
because o your body no because you just
find it from your subconscious and they
can kind of like they hack into things
of that nature
dang I forgot where I heard or read this
but then that though because they sent
out like emails like baby emails to
someone before they knew like what am I
getting all these email yeah that is
genius I need to get that that's all I
got
there's a guy that as a joke Pete on a
pregnancy test and it showed up positive
and you posted on reddit and then a few
doctors I read it said you need to go
get that checked out and turned out
there was something wrong with his balls
it's positive
the thought is being funny and Danny I
like ball cancer yeah pretty much my
legs like now all the pregnant teens can
afford a pregnancy test go to your local
IKEA and pick up a bag but this is
Sweden in Sweden yeah bright those
burning teens in Sweden there's house up
[Music]